Man, what is going on with Bruce Willis these
days?
Its sad, isnt it?
Its like he’s sleepwalking.
Good Day to Die Hard is, like, the worst Die
Hard movie ever.
No.
Good Day To Die Hard is not a Die Hard movie.
If the original Die Hard is Wrath of Khan,
then Good Day to Die Hard is The Voyage Home.
Alright?
Its not even close.
Olympus Has Fallen is more of a Die Hard movie
than Good Day to Die Hard.
No, Olympus Has Fallen is Die Hard.
Like, literally.
Beat for beat.
They just changed the setting and most of
the actors.
Otherwise, same movie.
Good Day to Die Hard wouldnt even have made
a good Taken sequel, man.
Thats how lazy it is.
Im on vacation!
Right.
Lets cram a catch phrase in because Die Hard
movies are supposed to have quotable lines,
right?
But its a lame catch phrase.
Thats what really bothers me.
Right.
It’s not even accurate.
Like, hes in Russia to get his son out of
prison.
Thats, like, the opposite of vacation.
Right?
Yeah.
Wait, did we just agree on something?
Its blowing my mind.
Feels weird, doesn’t it?
Well, its the first time you’ve been right
about something.
I imagine that would feel weird, or strange.
All Im saying is Bruce Willis is making either
terrible movies these days, or just doing
walk-on cameos in terrible movies.
Alright, GI Joe Retaliation, you have both
Expendables movies, you’ve got Surrogates.
The list goes on--
Looper.
Dude, Looper is great!
Im telling you.
Ive told you that several times.
Well, I wouldnt know.
Somebody wont let me watch it.
Cop Out.
Man, don’t even get me started on Cop Out.
Why?
Kevin Smith, man.
I f*cking hate that guy.
Dude, I know Cop Out is not great, but Chasing
Amy is great.
Jay & Silent Bob still makes me laugh.
You dont like Kevin Smith movies?
I didnt say anything about his movies, man.
I hate him.
Dude, how can you hate Kevin Smith, man?
He makes funny movies, gives awesome talks,
hes got, like, a trillion kick-ass podcasts.
Podcasts.
2003 called.
They want their cutting edge media format
back.
Well, now thats just an ignorant statement,
man.
Podcasts has never been more popular.
Well, maybe if we wasnt doing so many f*cking
podcasts he would have time to answer my fan
mail.
You sent him fan mail?
What did you send him?
I sent him a picture I wanted him to sign.
Well, what was the picture of?
Me.
You sent a famous actor and movie director
a picture of yourself and asked him to sign
it and you are surprised that he didnt do
it?
Not surprised… vengeful.
Ive been plotting my revenge ever since.
Can you get this?
I cant get this.
Well, all Im saying is… people usually get
autographs from the star—
Exactly.
Can you imagine how rare it would be?
Think about what Im gonna be able to sell
this thing for.
Alright, nobody on the planet has a picture
of me autographed by Kevin Smith.
Well, rarity is only good enough when youve
got demand.
People have to want the thing that youre trying
to sell, alright?
I could put a jar of my own crap on Ebay and
call it a one-of-a-kind item.
And that may very well be true.
But that doesnt mean anybodys gonna buy it.
I think you underestimate the kind of people
that hang out on the Internet..
Somebody would totally buy that.
But I also think you underestimate people
who like my videos.
They might want a photo of me.
I dont want to brag or anything, but have
you seen the YouTube stats?
We have got, like, tons of subscribers now.
You only got most of those subscribers because
Kevin Smith tweeted about you in the early
going!
Well, I know.
Thats all well and good.
But if he thinks thats gonna square things
for his sins against me personally, well,
hes got another thing coming.
Well, Im just saying people dont like your
channel because of your looks.
And they dont want pictures of you autographed
by Kevin Smith, alright?
Thats not what they want.
Well, I cant sell that anyway.
At least not until I get it.
You are never gonna get it.
Thank you, En Vogue.
Heres your damn toy.
How did you do that?
Youve gotta look at the packaging, buddy.
This is for big kids.
5 and up.
You know what?
F*ck your face.
Im out of here.
Do you want me to autograph a picture of you?
Probably worth as much money.